thank you
[Music]
presidential field has just expanded
significantly so did you guys know Mike
Pence is jumping in he wants to run for
Prezi oh he's Mike Vince is making a
comeback the vice president wants to
compete with against Trump whoa him and
Trump had beef at the end huh big time
has that ever happened
um I don't remember I mean like so so
Bush and Reagan right like when it was
Reagan versus bush in like 80 whatever
[__] 80 or just before that and Bush
senior Bush senior and they were
competing with each other and then
Reagan added Bush to the ticket to kind
of heal all the wounds so that happens
but I don't know if there's been a a
president who had a vice president yeah
had him compete pretty interesting so
yeah Pence is getting in next week
the field is expanding to Trump DeSantis
uh this chick named Joni Ernst that's
cool okay Joni what's up girl right what
you got Joni
um how did Republicans view Mike Pence
oh wait nerds isn't getting in wait wait
real quick Trump the scientist Nikki
Haley
um that guy Tim Scott
um and then yes but are most of these
guys like less than like a percent of a
chance and then the bottom at the end
yeah yeah what was your question how do
people view Mike Pence like Republicans
specifically aren't they like he's like
a backstabber I think there's a lot if
he's a backstabber but then there's like
maybe a slice of the party who's like we
need like more politeness well what
about the santis that's pretty cool but
I think the reason why Trump had him as
vice president was to win the Bible Belt
yeah because
um Trump did it so like traditional old
school Republicans are like the Bible
Belt Republicans right yeah and then
Trump is a New Yorker and he was a
Democrat for most of his life that's why
trumpsters are trumpsters right because
he had a lot of former Obama voters and
working class white and also like people
that were just not a part of politics
and he brought them in and then he
didn't really get the Republican Party
Support and the neoconservatives because
I mean like each political party it's
not one group right it's like
there's like different no they don't
like them I think now they do though
well they have actually kind of like
yeah well the head of the Republican
party right her name's
um Branham
um um Romney McDaniel some [__] like
that she's a Romney and Mitt Romney and
Trump don't like each other there's beef
oh they got Matt B Mappy but then she
was cool with Trump when he was
president right because she was the head
of the Republican party at his request
basically or he like allowed her to be
dead because if you're the president
you're the head of the party yeah but
they're not clicked up though they're
not like they're not they don't have the
same idea ideas and then I thought it
was interesting that I thought the
Republican cap would be way more tighter
than a democratic Camp because the
Democratic Camp is like way bigger with
different groups right but then they
keep talking about how like oh
Republicans we need to like vote like
Democrats we need to get behind each
other and I was like what the hell is
that the other way around that's what I
thought but it's
santis and some people like Trump oh
yeah yeah someone like 40 ahead of
DeSantis right now ahead of him yeah
he's way ahead so yeah
oh get him again dude
he did a weird roll out though like when
he came out right he runs he says I'm
running for president but before that he
did this book tour oh yeah he like only
talks to like local radio guys and [__]
like in his in the State of Florida or
whatever he doesn't go to like a lot of
these bigger places so people don't
really know much about him they're not
hearing [__] about it because there's
like this new alternative media [__] all
over YouTube and all over like different
social media platforms right like
Twitter and stuff and he's not going on
those places he's too old school yeah
he's doing the old school way that they
did like like in the 2000s because
having a book when you run for president
that's pretty common right that's what
they do it's part of the marketing
strategy right so write a book yeah they
have You released read my story and
that's your platform you know that's
what you're gonna run on and then you go
out and do the media rounds and [__]
like that and he was doing the very
traditional way it's like whoever's
running his campaign so they're like old
school AM radio yeah literally literally
he's reading his book though so my next
question yeah
is it only white people that are running
oh no Tim Scott's running who's this Tim
Scott Senator Tim Scott in South
Carolina what is he he's watching oh he
is he can't trust him here
why can't we trust that that's I asked
two questions you can't trust them can
you because I don't know it's a horrible
question in South Carolina
and I I asked that genuinely because
it's like I mean I guess since Obama
like I mean who who else tried to
[__] who else trying to run like what
business is he from Tim Scott like what
was his thing yeah what yeah he's a
republican yeah
thanks thanks fellow hosts
oh nothing beats host [__] house
[Laughter]
it's actually a good question so he says
that um with the perm [__] yeah
yeah was he in boys in the hood
Tim was in boys in the hood right yeah
Nick was sitting over there is he Ricky
from uh yeah he's a small business owner
who got into politics oh cool that's all
they said huh there's no more grades and
graduates from Charleston Southern
University built his own successful
small business and then he um yeah he
got into public service elected to
Charleston County city council uh so he
just claimed the politics ladder
basically representatives and then he
got into the center so let me let me ask
you guys a question because I know how I
feel like how do you guys feel about
people being fans of these politicians I
think it's ridiculous okay it doesn't
make sense is this the weirdest thing to
me it doesn't make sense it's weird it's
really fun
but Trump rallies with the [__] merch
dog merch Decked Out Trump bracelet
[__] pearls like all [__] they're
hardcore I see people with bumper
stickers I'm like what or Flags like you
put that [__] on your [__] car I
think it makes sense to be fans of
someone's policies but like I don't I
don't get that like what it's like
you're they're sports teams yeah I mean
how many of those [__] do you think
actually read their policies and get
into it that's another thing too no it's
like positions that never read the Bible
about this [__] so for instance like
like people think the homeless problem
here is Biden's problem but it's not
right it's been a problem
but people don't that's what I'm saying
I'm like but how are we gonna solve how
can you solve the homeless problem when
he's tripping fun all the time
he out there tripping over homeless dog
yeah they do they correlate that Jessica
the Oval Office keeps tripping the phone
on his shoes yeah but it's weird though
like I think the whole fan [__] like
when people just it is yeah they're
rocking like a flag and they're like the
merch like if you're watching merch you
dork the rest of the country though I
mean the rest of the other door the
world thinks we're weird yeah you rock
your politician merch what other country
is doing that
think about
[Laughter]
half of the time is spending time
campaigning to try to win again it's
entertainment
like two [__] years to campaign are
you [__] serious I mean I just find
it crazy if anybody even is a fan of
every single policy from any candidate
you got to disagree with something yeah
yeah yeah especially if you're if you're
a republican you gotta disagree with
some Republicans it might be something
that doesn't hit like you know that's
the weird part for me it's like we
should have more moderates and then the
minority should be like left black and
Asians
yeah
and most should be moderate while
they're because that's real Humanity
right like it's like we're like all
mostly in the middle and we're just like
maybe we're right wing here or left wing
here on some issues on some issues right
yeah but no what the with the way it is
now it's like you're way over here or
you're way over here
it's so unnatural I mean they'll leave
me the [__] alone and stop inflating my
currency party yeah
stop inflating my [__] crazy I'm
giving my money away yeah leave me alone
is a great party that's a great party
yeah
I like the birthday party you like the
birthday birthday party that's because
I'm a big fan of the birthday party said
if he gets elected it'll be like every
day is our birthday and I think that's
such a sick [__] policy
what does he mean by that you say that
really you really said that yeah what do
you mean it's Kanye what do you think
the answer is just yes the answer is
yeah of course always never be shocked
and then he started putting boots on as
gloves and then he said yeah what a zany
guy you see that picture of him walking
around and his girl has like a mask like
she's covering her head up with a
sweater and then he's wearing like
football pads yeah it looks cool you see
that one was he wearing white
did you like it in style yeah kind of
sick you gotta get some shoulder pads
if anyone who do you guys listen to him
politically oh I [__] with him politics
how does someone [__] with him
politically I [__] with all of it no man
the birthday party thing I don't even
know what he's saying
every day disagree with that man that's
a mission that's a policy statement
that's like the [__] when you run for
class president at school you just say
funny [__] yeah to make people laugh you
want fun I want Coke out of the water
fountain
if I'm president pizza party every day
every day not just every Friday every
day I'm opening a Chipotle in your
homeroom so is it so do y'all still bump
Kanye's music of course yeah same I'm a
big fan still College Dropout I know how
to separate the person from the
character yeah like but I think that's
because we're in entertainment right you
know like most of these [__]
have a persona but then the real world
like they're really just watching people
and thinking that that's who they really
are oh yeah some like like I mean I want
to be in Kanye's brain for like a day
yeah just to see like you think you can
handle it because I bet it's like 50
million differently let me take that
back 10 minutes you think there's a
chance you wouldn't come back oh [__] no
I I would I wouldn't I was in there too
long pull him out pull it out pull the
[__] plug yeah I was like this
I would have to leave I would have to I
couldn't be in that brain that long I'm
just I just want to know how he gets to
where he gets because like musically
like when we listen to his music we
[__] get it genius yeah get it if he
did like of course you know if he was if
he went and spoke on a Podium about
music yeah oh dude I'm listening
it wouldn't be wrong but when he starts
going into this political [__] I'm like
I feel like he his heart's in the right
place but he just goes too far too often
yeah too long and too far into the Jews
did you watch The Lex Freeman thing his
podcast with him no no oh he's doing a
stocking the whole yeah
yeah
and it was it was recent it was the one
before the Alex Jones one oh yeah oh
okay so it was before he completely went
off the resume oh Alex Jones
but like next time I do this [__]
show
what would you hear him talk you go like
okay he's like I I kind of get what he's
saying but then he spends 15 minutes too
long on one topic and then you're like
oh and it's kind of going in circles
like that's what I felt when he was on
uh the last one I watched was when he
was on a pierce yeah here's Morgan yeah
yeah that's the last one I watched and I
was like oh I mean I'm like how can like
it's so exhausting yeah and the fact
that people give it that much attention
is [__] insane and they stay in the
pocket in a conversation like that and
like people are just like oh my God I
didn't hear what he said yeah yeah
yeah it's also pretty pretty interesting
too because he's like who can't we talk
about who can't we talk about who can we
talk about it's like dude you're being
lit really well right now in the studio
broadcast everyone
you tell me who we can't talk I'm
actually talking about him right now
tell me yeah
I don't know I just I just don't think
he's someone that you should take that
serious
you see that video this is my favorite
what does he do oh you invited them in
no that well I don't think you're about
what was it yeah he was four in the
morning in his front yard or something
like that and his garage he's opening it
up and then there's a Paparazzi guy
outside and he goes Morning Kanye and he
goes shut
he's like what do you expect me to do to
do say to you
four in the morning God [__] front
lines that is hard that's hard yeah but
that's the least crazy [__] he's ever
said yeah yeah yeah that's relatable
actually yeah yeah that's what I was
like I like this I like that policy
that's a good policy and there was one
where he's walking with Kim I think and
he doesn't see a sign and he hits his
head on the sign and I was like oh and
the way he gets he's like he's he
because like he really hit something in
your head and you feel so mad that
you're like I'm a [__] [__] and
because you hit your head and it hurts
and then you know that people are
watching you do it you're like you feel
even more embarrassed and I watch that
and I go that guy could be our president
what
I see you going there you got one over
all right got it did you see when he uh
what the [__] did he do oh he uh his
Uber was taking forever and there's
Paparazzi there and then he has to
Paparazzi to give him a ride
it's a man of the people yeah Uber
driver and you're like Kanye yeah
great yeah yeah